Kim Il-Sung's grandson, Jong-Nam, was sacked
as heir to North Korea after being arrested
trying to enter Japan on a false passport
to visit Disneyland
When
customers visited the UK's first supermarkets
they were afraid to pick up goods in case
they were told off.
Since smoking was banned in 2004, the main
currency in US prisons is mackerel.
It was 33 years after loo paper was invented
in Green Bay, Wisconsin, that it could finally
be advertised as 'splinter free'.
The shortest war ever fought was between Britain
and Zanzibar on August 27, 1896.
Zanzibar surrendered after 38 minutes.
Kestrels can locate voles from the sky because
of ultra-violet light reflected by their urine.
Bubblewrap was first produced in a New Jersey
garage in 1957.
Its inventors were trying to make easy-wipe
textured wallpaper.
Between 1917 and 1940, the cure for patients
with syphilis was to give them malaria.
Since its discovery in 1930, Pluto has travelled
only a third of its way round the Sun.
The proud owner of the first silicone breast
implant was a dog called Esmeralda.
Nelson Mandela was not removed from the US
terror watch list until 2008.
Almost half of all Americans today are classified
as 'living in poverty'. 46% pay no income
tax.
The word hundred is derived from the word
"hundrath", which actually means 120 and not
100.
Sucking a king's nipples was a gesture of
submission in ancient Ireland.
In Japan, Tintin is called Tantan because
Tintin is pronounced 'Chin-Chin' and means
'penis'.